sir oh I believe you said that the men
that go into the Amazon come out changed
for you making the film embrace of the
serpent and being in the Amazon how did
you come out changed basically the movie
if I had to put it difficult to put it
into words because it's a life
experience and but you know III if I had
to resume it I would say that I lost a
lot of weight emotional weight
intellectual spiritual weight that I had
you know there I was at the beginning of
and before I was so overwhelmed with
questions without and this this process
of being with them on learning from them
or hearing them and try to translate
them for a foreign audience Hey I found
it very rewarding but also yeah the best
way I can describe it is that you know I
feel much lighter now Breann for you I
believe you do a lot of character back
work and that you write a lot in your
character's voice and almost seem to
know the character better than the
filmmaker does can you take us through
that process
how are you developing that character's
voice usually it's its extensive amounts
of writing and journaling journaling as
the character reading whatever I can
especially in this case considering it
was a real human being but during the
character work always until a biography
learning everything I can from the when
did he was born when Richard was you
know early in his you know five six
seven he got really sick but he gained
this obsession for plants which carried
him through his life and then just
learning what will drove him to be the
person that he was and be passionate
about literally the Amazon and how I can
relate to that and bring that passion
and to my own understanding of my own
passion so intellectually I did a lot of
work leading up to going to the Amazon
and then once I got there I realized
that all I had to do was let go and
observe and trust in Siro and Trust in
the experience that
Amazon was going to take care of and my
own observation was also that of of
Evans the languages was the most
difficult intellectually to to memorize
for sure it was ten hours a day just
over and over and over and it was just
in my mouth and I could just say it and
still thinking in English and and my
motivation my intention was in English
you know the character with her than me
oh well with that you know you know
knowing the character I think it's the
responsibility of the actor to go in
with an extensive because I only have to
worry about my character and to bring in
to Siro and give him options and give
the director options so that he can say
yes and no and then we work on molding
the person together which was an
incredible experience to have with zero
and I remember the day it clicked with
both of us and I just wanted to add
about this character Richard that you
research you know just to give an idea
of the importance of he has you know if
botanist manages to in his lifetime to
discover one new plant he that's what
that would be like a life achievement a
Richard Evan shoulders we which is he
since the character inspired discover
two hundred and fifty so that's gives
you an idea of unnamed thirty thousand
plants he named you know for scientific
research and thousands of plants I know
some of the beliefs of the shamans were
that you respect the rhythms of the
jungle that you leave it untouched
I believe in hiking they have the saying
leave nothing take nothing so when
you're in the Amazon shooting how are
you dealing with it yeah we didn't we
didn't have the logic of you know
bringing and foreign production logic
and you know trying to just clear the
jungle and put whatever we needed you
just try to make a take advantage of the
of the of what of what the place offered
us and try to make as little impact as
possible and also we take always with
the guidance of the local communities
because they have these are people who
have lived in the jungle
10,000 years so they know the jungle and
they know how to respect and we had to
listen to them it wasn't about us
telling the guy selling their rules but
you know listening to how they work and
trying to make our film within those
rules was this more of a spiritual
experience rather than an artistic or
career move yeah definitely more it was
yeah I feel that a film you don't choose
this here the film so much the film
chooses you the story chooses you and
when once it chooses you and you feel
you feel that like that that's what you
have to do you don't you're not thinking
about where it is whether it's going to
be successful whether it's going to be
good for your career or something like
that you just need to tell this story
and you need to give it everything you
got and and it become and just making it
becomes the reward in itself certainly
that was the experience for me as well I
mean this film is everything in this
film the philosophy of this film is
everything that I stand for in life and
to be and to watch how I got to play
this role and have this experience it's
just a testament to myself only Bo being
open to what my life is supposed to mean
and it's supposed to be and my career is
just a a vocal piece of that